national master james canton iii here
with chess.com and today
we have gang of the day with the white
pieces we have stock fish and with the
black pieces we have leela chess
zero let's get right into it here we are
we have e4
and c5 a sicilian right something we're
all used to
one of the sharpest ways to play against
e4 and after c5 there's knight f3 and
knight c6 world championship
fashion as we'll say because we saw a
lot of ross limo in the last world
championship with fabiano and magnus
bishop to b5
will be a move here but uh we can just
play d4 and after d4 their c takes and
knight takes where you can go in
multitude of ways here playing d6
or e6 or knight f6 stretching a cough
fashion
even e5 or a6 all these moves even g6
as well there's many moves you can make
but this one is a new one oh no here we
go
d5 what is this i have never seen it in
my entire
life i don't know about you but this
move right here is actually called the
nimzo american variation
that's a new sicilian to me probably new
to you as well
but of course we learn a lot from these
engines so very very strong stuff d5
e takes d5 queen takes d5 and now bishop
to e3 now i think black's actually
already equal here
just having open open line for the
bishop another one's coming no
weaknesses for both sides fairly an
equal game this is probably why you
don't see d5
at uh at the the bigger levels and
higher levels and even in your own games
d5 is just not a move
that usually we would play but now we
can start playing it because
leela zero's playing it so bishop e3
knight to f6
developing knight to c3 attacking the
loose queen that is already out
queen of d6 and after queen to d6 knight
takes c6 can be answered with queen
takes or
pawn takes uh c6 but after queen to d6
no trade says stockfish
bishop e2 we're just going to keep
developing bishop d7 same for black if
you notice
every move they're trying to develop
pieces as much as possible because you
still got to get the pieces off the back
ring to make this thing work
after bishop to d7 we'll watch this very
strong move here knight b
knight d to b5 and attacking the queen
if queen takes d1 you have rook takes
knight c7 is looking fine and knight
takes a7 can be a thing if you think
about castling
or rook to c8 in those fashions so not
fun for black so
instead we go queen to b8 this is a move
that you will see a lot in the french
defense advance variation
or usually sometimes the milner berry
gambit sort of times where you game the
pawn on d4 queen sits on b8 but
the difference is there's no pawns in
the center at all so this is a little
bit different you would love to get
bishop f4 in but that can always be
answered with e5
and a6 is definitely coming so you need
to move fast says white
so uh queen b8 queen of d2 really
nothing we could do here
nothing strong besides bishop f4 a6 is
coming anyway
because when they cross the line what's
the line you ask well anything one to
four
is wall white and anything eight to five
five to eight is all of black's pieces
anything that crosses the line that is
not my piece needs to go
so this knight on b5 is is very live and
he got to go so a6 is a big boy move
kicking the knight a6 and now we could
just move the knight now the best
defense is offense i love to say this
all the time
because it's true before you actually go
into defense
can you do anything offensive first now
let's see we do have bishop f4 but
that's going to be answered with e5
rook d1 they can just take it because
this is not actually attacked at all
maybe castles or castle queenside kind
of the same thing so you might just have
to move this knight
or play uh something like bishop b6
oh yeah we going for it says stockfish
oh we're about that life for real
bishop b6 while with knight c7 and we
send him to heaven that game is going to
be over knight c7 is going to be very
very strong here bishop b6 is a big boy
move
wow from a big boy like stockfish for
big engine bishop b6
now after captures which did happen
because knight c7 is detrimental
after a takes b5 knight takes b5 knight
c7 is checked
plucks real hard it's going to be some
trouble here so kind of no way to stop
this knight d5 is always answered with
queen takes d5
and so we have e6 after e6 there is
knight c7
and then king e7 and this is about to
get very strange here guys
very very strange and we say strange
because like as a human
we would make much different moves than
you would see from a computer of course
they can just calculate
way more than we can in depth with
accuracy
to the uh the utmost extent so king to
e7
we would love to get queen d6 in but he
plays bishop f3 it says stockfish goes
for bishop f3
which is attacking the c6 knight as well
um just and also this move here stops 94
which is extremely strong
and very annoying 94 was a very strong
move so bishop f3 is actually necessary
which is pretty good it's just hard to
find this move bishop f3 and then
there's rook a4 stepping out of the way
saying well
if you're not going to take the rook i'm
not going to give you another chance so
after rook 2a4 there's capsule queen
side threatening stuff like queen to d6
but miraculously after rook c4 queen d6
it looks like game over but it's
actually not
and this is where computers of course
are just better than us in this area
of calculation now let's actually see
what happens after queen d6 king d8
and then you actually don't have any
super cool moves besides just maybe
either taking
where he can sidestep you either way
actually which is kind of strange how he
can just sidestep us like this
but of course knight after knight to b5
is king to e8
and actually you're just kind of
repeating moves actually according to
the engine literally it's zeros right
now
that is insane if you do anything else
you're not winning but this is
zeros like ins how is this zero zero
what
you know what i mean right after king
eight it's just that's amazing that's
absolutely amazing there but after
castle queenside rook to c4
understanding that there's nothing
there's nothing at all so after rook c4
there's b3 attacking the rook
and say all right you know what you
cross the line like we said when you
cross the line you got to go
so we play b3 to attack the rook go
somewhere rook to d4
saying all right cool hey go ahead take
it because if you take it i'm going to
take on c7 and actually in this position
it's a fairly equal a little bit better
slightly better for black believe it or
not
well why well let's look at the piece
count one two three four five six
and then one two three four five but you
have to remember of course white
sacrificed that piece
early on so doing uh bishop takes d4
looks good but it's not actually the
best move in fact we play queen to g5
and we live threatening things like
queen c5 and also rook takes d4 and
in a lot of cases but queen c5 is
definitely a strong move queen g5 so
rook takes which is a forcing move
and rook takes d1 to follow up keep
pressure on the file with a smile
and now after rook takes d1 there's
queen to ca stepping out of the way
defending d7 a little bit more
things like rook d7 could be in the air
but you don't want to sack too many
pieces
because you won't have enough firepower
to actually win the game because you
sack
all your pieces you don't have anything
left so queen to c8
nice move here from stockfish actually
playing b4 here which is something i
didn't see
i didn't consider at all you're trying
to get these moves to work is what they
call the loud moves which is like queen
b4
check bishop c5 is a loud move it's just
in your face
bishop takes c6 rook takes d7 these are
all possibilities maybe even queen back
to d2
and in fact b4 is actually a move that
many people would miss before more of a
quiet move more of a strange looking
surprising move b4 h6 and instead of
queen c5
in fact there's a better move when you
find a good move look for a better one
and based off calculation and depth that
they have here that they they are able
to do queen c5 still works is plus four
here
but queen e3 believe it or not is plus
eight here queen e3 is just a better
move believe it or not sometimes chess
is extremely just a hard game
chess is hard we all know this right
queen to e3 now of course
as a human you could win with queen to
c5 queen to c5
king d8 knight takes c7 then you take
this way and then we rook check
and there's all kind of things that
happen afterwards from this but there's
a lot of things that can happen with
that being said though
queen to e3 is a move chosen by
stockfish after queen to e3 there is a
knight to h7
we have to make moves like f5 maybe g5
or f6 and
you got to develop we only use how many
pieces class raise your hand right
one piece two three four versus you know
these other two and we're supposed to be
up a piece
but we're really not up a piece with
this piece like sitting over here in a
corner
not doing anything not helping us at all
so after knight h7 there's b5 kicking
the knight this is what we wanted to do
and a a very good uh tip to remember
when you're attacking
is try to remove any and every piece
that is around the king that could help
defend
so b4 and b5 makes total sense here
because we're trying to remove the
knight
that is helping in some of the defensive
aspects of black's position so after b5
knight to b8 so we can keep the uh we
can still keep our
our piece um says black here but look at
our pieces it's just a gross position
to be in you would love to be white in
this position now after knight to ba
guys
look around the board there's many moves
you can make i was surprised by this one
that should maybe give you some kind of
hit but you probably still won't get it
wrong
well pause the video and check this one
out white to move what would you play
here it is guys well stockfish says
bishop h5
and we live in fact this move to me
almost
made no sense at all because i've
who how many of you would play bishop h5
in this position
how many of you would have played bishop
h5 that's just
a we call that an engine move because
they definitely saw something
that we did not see here bishop h5 is
very strong is actually cutting off some
of the squares and if the
necessity or playing something like f6
or f5 now is just running into queen c5
automatically
you know because you can't go to king f7
king d8 is not great and you can't go
king e8
at all and you actually made it there
nasty checkmate there with a double
check on the king
so pretty nasty stuff bishop h5 is just
a very strange but strong move
like really strong watch this after
bishop h5 g6 says back that thing up
please
you cannot come over here i don't want
you all in the house like this you're
after g6 there's queen to d4
attacking the rook well equal or
stronger threats which is of course the
best defense being offense
if you're attacking my bishop i'm going
to attack your rook rook g8 and then
after rook g8 now we're going in for the
kill queen d6 of course
and after queen d6 there's king d8 after
king d8 well hey
you know what time it is knight takes e6
we in the mix that's the double check
there
flex real hard can go cea because you
have to and here we go
knight c7 now what why did we go back
think about this right
what's the difference in this position
and this position
right here this position and then go
back this position
if you said the pawn you are 100 correct
actually knight takes e6 removes the
pawn from the e file that was closed
and then king e8 knight c7 now the e
file is open oh my goodness
wow you in trouble big fella you in
trouble
knight c7 and now after knight c7 let's
actually take a look at what happens on
king to d8
king to d8 we have queen e5 which is a
better move because you would just keep
repeating moves and actually knight d5
followed by knight f6 check doesn't work
because the knight can actually capture
and your queen and the bishops hang
a lot of stuff hanging but after king d8
queen e5 is the best move here in fact
actually threatening queen to e8
mate why because there's a pin here very
very strong pin
after queen e5 they have bishop a3
finally
i can get a piece out then king to b1
and then
f6 just trying to get rid of the queen
but in fact
you actually lose you forgot about this
other mate on the other side of the
board start a new one
have a good day well it's actually not
made you have to block with the queen
but this is gross this is gross nobody
wants to play this one out
this one's game over so now with that
being said after knight c7
black is forced to take with the queen
after queen takes well rookie one
in between move or justin joke and then
after rookie one check there's bishop b6
after bishop b6 queen takes c7
knight to c6 and after knight c6 of
course
stopping the mate we just take it take
the knight
bishop a3 a83 check king b1 and king f8
and we great trying to get out of the
way
trying not to be mated here and then
what are we going to do we're going to
cut off the escape square because the
king is trying to head for the hills
do whatever he can here to not get made
it bishop d4 stopping king g7
f6 to stop of course to mate because if
anything else happens for instance pawn
takes well it's simple
mate and we great to start a new game
this is a family channel so let's go
back now bishop to d4
after bishop d4 there's f6 and rook
takes e6 nasty move here
just eliminating all the pieces that you
have what a game
after rook h8 well that's game over can
you find the kill shot here
tactics win games i hope you did your
puzzle rush today so it is white to move
here what are you gonna do
here it is guys well rook e8 and we
great what a big boy move
from a big engine like stockfish rookie
eight that's nasty
after king takes of course because it's
forced you don't have any other move
bishop takes g6 and then after king f8
queen f7 oh yeah that's checkmate
checkmate
and we great amazing game here sacrifice
from the beginning now of course we did
see a very weird sicilian with that d5
move
maybe not try that one at home but
definitely you can try out exactly what
uh white did today
and it's knight to d to b5 bishop b6
stuff which was very nice to see
from a game like today so i hope you
enjoyed it this was game of the day
i'm national master james canty iii here
with chess.com
and i'll see you guys on the next video